على مدار ايام سيطر اسمان على المسامع عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد الجيش السوداني ومحمد
حمدان دقلو قائد قوات الدعم السريع القوات
التي تخضع لكل منهما تخوض معارك محتدمه في
شوارع الخرطوم احتراب اندلعت شرارته
الاولى يوم الخامس عشر من ابريل ولا تزال
راحه دائره
تساؤلات تتنامى مع تطور المواجهه لعل
ابرزها لماذا يتجنب الخصمان الذهور لا احد
يمكن ان يجزم بمقر اقامه الخصمين خاصه ان
كل طرف يصر على الحسم فهي معركه وجوديه او
صفريه بقاء احد الطرفين يعني ان الاخر خرج
من المعادله السودانيه
عصر اليوم الاول من المعارك
ظهر البرهان في الخرطوم لخمسه عشره ثانيه
في مقطع مصور يرجح ان يكون التقط داخل
احدى غرف العمليات العسكريه من مقر
القياده العامه وبجواره قائد الحرس
الرئاسي ومجموعه من العسكريين يتابعون
الاحداث المشتعله ثلاثه اماكن قد يوجد
فيها البرهان داخل الخرطوم اما في قصر
الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري او القياده
العامه للجيش وهي الاماكن التي حاولت قوات
الدعم السريع السيطره عليها وفي السابع
عشر من ابريل قصفت قوات الجيش احد المقرات
في حي المطار حيث رجحت القوات المسلحه
وجود قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حمدتي
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان دارفور قد تكون
ملاذا امنا لحميتي في حال استمرت المعارك
حيث يتمتع هناك بنفوذ وسيطره ربما لا
يتوفران لديه في الخرطومه يكتفي كل من
البرهان وحميتي بالحديث الى وسائل الاعلام
هاتفيا وعلى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينقل
البرهان تصريحاته نصا عبر الصفحات الرسميه
للجيش السوداني بينما يلجا الى النصر عبر
حساباته على تويتر وفيسبوك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات